[موسيقى]
مخلب أجنبي يحتوي على كل شيء في المحيط الهادئ
عبر
الجبال وصولًا إلى المحيط الهادئ
عبر الجبال مرة أخرى وصولاً
إلى بحر كورتيز
وهو أمر مذهل وبمجرد
قيامك بذلك يدخل دمك ويتعلق
باجا لا ترحم ،
فهي لا تهتم
ولا تهتم بمقدار ما أعددته ، ولا تهتم
بالمال الذي
أنفقته ، ولا تهتم بقدر الخبرة التي
لديك
إذا
أخطأت في إحدى المرات ، فسوف تعضك
[موسيقى]
نعم ، كانت إحدى ولاياتنا الأولى في
أحد سباقاته الأولى في الواقع في
سباق رباعي التحمل لمدة 24 ساعة كان
يتسابق ، لذا أعتقد أنه
أدرك في تلك اللحظة ما إذا كان بإمكانها
النجاة في سباق لمدة 24 ساعة كما تعلم
في الصحراء  قد تكون حارسًا
[موسيقى]
إنها مجنونة ،
إنه مجرد تحدٍ بالنسبة لي في الواقع ،
لقد استلهمتني من زوجي واين
لأنه عندما بدأنا السباق لأول مرة ، كان
هذا هو الطريقة التي فضل القيام بها ،
وكان يرغب في تسويتها ويحبها جيدًا إذا
كان بإمكانه  يمكنني القيام بذلك ، لذلك بدأت في
القيام بذلك و  هذا فقط ما أفضل
أن أكون امرأة في هذه
الرياضة التي يسيطر
عليها الذكور ، لقد كانت تقدمية بالنسبة لي في
البداية ، أود أن أقول
إنهم ربما لم يأخذوني على
محمل الجد ولكن
بمجرد أن
بدأت بالفوز وأنت تعلم وأثبت
لهم أنني  في الخارج لمجرد أن يكون
رياضيًا ومنافسًا آخر
لا تعرفه فقط من أجل المتعة
فهم
بخير  دراجاتهم من الحرير قبل
[موسيقى]